okay so today I'm here to talk about how
I like to tinker in the cloud with our
and how I like to through my job at our
studio support other people doing the
same thing and becoming more familiar
with this concept that we call analytic
administration so I was listening to a
podcast and very bad I don't remember
where this came from or what podcast or
who said it but I like the idea of
lowering the cost of turning our ideas
that we as data scientists produce into
reality so I really liked when I heard
this on a podcast that if you have
something of value and a PayPal account
you can start an online business in
minutes and at our studio I you our goal
in developing these tools and
applications are marked down documents
as doing kind of the same thing but for
data science so yesterday we heard a lot
of great talks that talked about shiny
and Emily talked about developing these
tools that helped her do her job better
help other people do their jobs better
and that's a mission that I really like
drew me to to apply to work for our
studio and and the reason that I feel so
passionate about working in this space
together so so if you have a data
science just a data analysis of value
and you have the proper data product
tool chain you should theoretically be
able to share that analysis with
everyone you know in minutes but as you
might have noticed or maybe you didn't
notice yesterday and a lot of the talks
they would get to the point where they
like we built this cool thing and then
what what comes next like where are they
and their organizations where they have
the ability to then distribute that data
product out to everyone in their
organization and really like spread the
things that they're building out to
everyone
a lot of the times I think in in smaller
organizations are ones that have not
embraced our as an analytic standard we
get to this point where like sure out my
local machine I can build something
really cool but then I'm kind of trapped
like how do I get this out to other
people like I don't want to ever be in
the position where I have this cool
burning idea and I don't have the tools
of the means to distribute it execute it
in the manner that I dreamed up but the
Internet is a beautiful wonderful place
and there are lots of tools for getting
this out there so as you progress in
your very creative and using the
internet you can do a number of things
basically for free to get your ideas out
to the world you could post a gif or a
screenshot to Twitter you could write a
blog post about it you could create a
github repository and share your code
through that you can also use these
publishing platforms that are hosted
like our pubs or shiny apps at i/o which
has a free tier but at a certain point
like especially if you're in the
situation where you're trying to do this
at work and you don't necessarily want
to put these things out on the public
Internet you start to run into some
blockers so the next two steps can be a
little bit more challenging they involve
like using servers dealing with IT
dragons fire linux administration
co-learning at space so at our studio we
are fully committed to this idea that
all organizations should have someone
inside of them who is a data scientist
who's decided to get like very uppity
and
sorry start doing what they need to do
to make our illegitimate analytic
standard within their business and that
involves like learning a little bit of
Linux administration onboarding new
tools deploying these solutions
supporting the data science team and the
existing standards that your IT
department has placed on you we'd like
them to work closely with IT if that's
at all possible and and help them
understand why are is so cool and so
important and why you love it so much so
how do you become this person if you're
interested in taking on this role it's a
little bit intimidating but there are
two main things that I'd like to share
today and one is but you need to get
yourself a sandbox a place to play
around in and this is like what I call
my tinkerer space and whether this is
something that you do at home on the
weekends in your spare time which is not
a healthy work-life balance that I like
to promote as an are ladies organizer or
if your organization is very cool and
and supports you in this mission maybe
you can get a server sandbox from them
either way like taking the initiative to
ask for this thing so that you can learn
the ropes of Linux and DevOps practice
with open source tools and then build
out these proof of concepts to develop a
sense for yourself of what the best
practices in this area are those are all
important things that will then lead you
to being able to support your IT
department in creating a secure analytic
infrastructure for your entire team so
at our studio I have kind of seen my job
is twofold I I really like to promote
best practices and doing smart things
with the tools that we have our
professional products but I also really
like to say you know like
if you're motivated by practical need
and burning curiosity tinkering is great
with one caveat and that's that's what I
alluded to in the previous slide where
we talk about developing a sense for
best practices so when you have a
sandbox you can do a lot of cool stuff
with it
and I've learned over time that there
are things that you can do and there are
things that you should do and those
aren't the same all the time so today I
would have run through like a tinkering
project that I did last summer for use
are and I want to talk about a couple of
cool cloud technologies involving
serverless and R but just bear in mind
that that I am not telling you that this
is a best practice so I want to talk
about plumber API switcher is a really
cool package package plumber developed
by a Jeff Allen who works on the our
studio konnekt team and he gave a
webinar about plumber back in July it's
now available on demand on our website
so do check it out if you're interested
maura just the other day yesterday or
something tweeted this she doesn't even
remember
and it just shows that people are
getting excited about using plumber
api's and and this person in particular
wrote our really according to Martha and
well-explained guide to using docker to
deploy plumber 8 the ice and and this
code on the side kind of shows you the
concept here you're basically getting
from very little essentially just adding
declarations to your code turning
functions that you've written in R into
rest api's the catch is you need
somewhere to serve these api's in order
for anyone outside of you working with
curl on your local machine to use them
at all so I've seen a lot of good
examples like the one I just threw up
the mark tweeted about people who've
used docker to serve these plumber api's
but I thought it would be cool to take
it another step further and use docker
in a server list
cloud computing environment if you
haven't heard of server list before it's
a little bit of a confusing term it's
not magic we're not like doing things
without servers it's basically a term
that said that means you're gonna hand
off the responsibility of managing this
infrastructure to someone else be it
Amazon or adjure or Google cloud and the
particular server list application
platform that I'm interested in using
for this project is Google App Engine
the Google App Engine came out in 2008
and I was in college at the time and I
was like this looks awesome
what does it do I don't know and I never
figured it out ten years later I read a
press release for them that they had now
had custom runtimes so I thought
thinking to myself hey I wonder if I can
put R in there again sandbox tinkering
not best practice necessarily I think
one of so the the basic idea is is that
you bring your code are otherwise and
you have Google cloud platform manage
all the infrastructure for you
and then theoretically you just pay for
what you use as I said R is not included
as a runtime by default they have this
popular crowd of runtimes that they
support are it's not one of them but
with the new custom runtimes you can
bring whatever you want inside of a
docker container so that's what I wanted
to set up I have two little app engines
here and one has plumber inside of
docker and it's serving this REST API
and then because I wanted to document it
and give people like a place to go to
learn about my rest endpoints I also
served up static HTML generated
mark town that was then being served by
nginx
oh I want to pause here to say I do I do
talk to a lot of people in in my
position who get very excited about
docker and I think it's an awesome very
cool technology and my opinion is that
it is awesome and cool when used in the
right situations and so you don't always
need to docker all the things but in
this particular case we do because
that's what I requires so the first part
of this project is that you create a
Google cloud project so you go to the
GCP console you sign it and you create
an account and then you create a project
you should also at this point
download install the Google Cloud SDK so
that you can view things from your
console you don't have to be doing it
from their console there are basically
three parts to a little Google App
Engine you need your docker file you
need your app demo file and this is
literally the entire contents of the app
demo file runtime custom environment
flex that's all you need and then you
need your assets this would be like the
plumber our script or the HTML generated
from our mark town those things and this
is the docker prep that I did for the
plumber app this is just reading in jeff
allen's plumber a docker image that he
has hosted for free on docker hub and
then what I've done is install an extra
package in there ggplot2 because my REST
API produces beautiful plots of iris
data so that people in Python can use
them and then I copy over the plumber
our file into the docker container and
then the final process here is just
exposing port 8080 because that's what
Google App Engine wants to listen on the
doctor prep for nginx is really super
simple as well I just read in the
official repository for nginx docker
image and then essentially the only
thing I do after that is add the static
content
so then we're basically at the final
step here you prepped your doctor files
created this app dot yamo file
gathered all of your our assets together
final two stages are running these two
commands g-cloud app create and g-cloud
app deploy it's at this stage that I
usually forget that I haven't attached
my billing account and like David Smith
was just saying a lot of these cloud
providers provide like free credit to
use and to tinker with
so he said adjure provides $200 GCP
provides $300 and you do have to usually
give them your own credit card
information when you attach these
accounts and that can be very scary but
you do get through GCP a lot of good
visibility into what's burning down this
free credit and how fast it's
disappearing so you can say boost up
burn it all down so that you can stop
getting charged if you need to be I also
want to mention that Google App engines
are not an instantaneous deployment
process by any means leave yourself at
least 15 minutes at least to get your
app up and running on Google cloud if
you need something with fast push button
deployment I work for our studio we have
products just getting started so once
you have this app running a serving
arrest API there are some other fun
things that you can do to prove to
yourself that this is running and
functional and and doing what you expect
it to in a serverless environment so
what I recommend is something really fun
so you can create these siege servers
using the siege utility and you can say
like I want this number of users I want
it like hit this API for this number of
seconds and you can add delay but
literally every time I run one of these
I keep I can't help in my mind like
yelling sea
it's just a lot of fun you can see it
running in real time and they're like
waiting to see and then you can see how
many failures or successes there were
hitting your API like I said I did this
original project for use are over the
summer so I have been tinkering with
extensions to it once you get them into
exploring these managed services that
these cloud providers have available
you'll learn that there are like sloughs
of them and they all do very interesting
different and and some of them are in
beta and some of them die off but but
this one in particular has caught my eye
recently this Google Cloud Composer
because it is a managed Apache airflow
service you haven't heard of Apache
airflow it's basically like if you were
to set up cron but get all of the
information you actually wanted to about
job scheduling so here's what I'd like
to build next and in my next sandbox I'd
like to explore this Google Cloud
Composer using Apache airflow so that I
can kind of track like a workflow in are
running off of REST API endpoints so
this would kind of be like a multi-step
process for training a model or running
like a series of our scripts on a
schedule that you wanted high visibility
into so you want to know like what's
running now how long is it taking I want
a visual diagram of where my job is over
time I want to know if it fails I'm
gonna get an email I want to know if
something suddenly starts running very
slow and all of this can be accomplished
through Apache airflow which i think is
really cool so this is my next project
it just so happens that it also runs
inside of a Google App Engine so as you
can see I'm slowly building up these
skills learning all of these managed
services for the
them together and cool new
configurations it'll have something to
do with our and getting a lot of joy out
of it finally you want to burn whatever
you've built in the sandbox down to the
ground because it wouldn't be in our
studio talk if I didn't talk about
burning things and this is how you do it
very explicitly go to settings and
utilities project settings shutdown we
want to stop getting charged when you're
done with your sandbox
lastly I'm really interested in in
building out these resources for people
who are interested in learning analytic
administration I'd really like to see an
analytic administrator become a
legitimate job title someday so if you'd
like to connect with me I've recently
written a little bit about learning
analytics and administration through
sandbox on our our views blog you can
check that out and I also am trying to
get this r admins hashtag going so wish
me luck with that thanks guys
[Applause]